oh god this one
[Music]
sleep no more oh
i'd really forgotten how bad this thing
is
no that's a lie i'd remembered how bad
it was
but re-watching it and going over it
with a fine-tooth comb
just finding more things beyond the
stuff that i remembered
being bad about it now
you know you can make the argument that
it's not as aggressively
bad as something like say kill the moon
but
oh my god it almost
nothing is working here and even the few
things that do work
are failing a bunch of the other times
let's start with the gimmick
because i'm sorry the first person
jumping between views thing is a gimmick
it is the absolute
heart of a gimmick it adds as much to
the story as the real time
thing did to 42 which is to say nothing
you could remove that element from the
story and it would change nothing about
the way the story is told
if you're going to do something that is
that fundamental to the con to
the episode in terms of how you're
presenting it like a real time thing
like this first person
but it doesn't actually alter the way
you tell the story
and you're not doing anything to take
advantage of what this actually does
and how it is meant to differ from any
other freaking
base under siege style story that doctor
who's ever done
then it's a gimmick and a poorly used
one at that here's the thing
there are lots that they could have done
to take more advantage of i'm not sure
what you could have done to actually
make it more central to the story
without making it disorienting
but there is at least one thing that
they could have done
to lean into the gimmick and make one of
the eventual
payoffs actually work worth a darn so
it is supposedly made up of various
pieces of footage captured some from the
what we are initially allegedly or the
head cams of the
rescue team coming in and then some from
the security cameras
of the uh station or whatever it is that
they are actually
on but here's
the thing it jumps perspective so
often and about with the regular rhythm
that you would expect a standardly cut
episode to be
and how frequent how frequently it goes
to
you know going out of a first person
into a third person
it just feels like a slightly awkwardly
edited standard episode
if it had stuck strictly
to the first person views of the various
characters and eliminated the
up top security angles every now and
then if it had completely
cut those then if nothing else the later
reveal that the doctor gave
of wait what's missing you know
the these things are in our heads and
these people we've never
we haven't seen anything from their
perspective and if you because if you
had stuck to perspectives you would have
realized
oh hey here it doesn't register because
you were jumping outside of people's
perspectives anyway so who the heck was
even going to think to keep
track or even have it register enough to
even
roll your mind back and go oh yeah no
it's completely pointless this entire
freaking gimmick
then there's the monsters so
oh boy there's there's oh god there's so
much about this
the core concept
i i try not to crap over core ideas
because
by and large i'm someone who ascribes to
the notion of
anything can be done well and even a bad
idea can be properly executed and i will
say that this is poorly executed but
i'll also argue that this is a bad idea
this core concept for these things that
it's
it's sleep dust it's the stuff in the
corner of your eyes that like
he takes over and eats you
i'm gonna make two complaints and they
might even sound contradictory
but stick with me here i have a higher
awareness of this now that i am a parent
which i wasn't
when this originally aired so issue one
it is too goofy on his face to take
seriously
especially when you see these things
like there are two shots
where these things actually look
effective in terms of being
monsters one the very first time we see
them where it's actually taking
advantage of the first person
perspective
and you get that found footage moment of
they're just kind of off of the
background like and you just see a
shadow move and everybody
bolts it's almost kind of like amnesia
the dark descent thing the minute you
see a bit of it you're like ah and you
go so you don't actually get a good look
at it but then almost immediately after
that and i do mean
almost immediately it you know it sticks
its arm through a door and we see
this lumpy foam looking thing
that isn't scary it just isn't it's too
bulky it's too it just it just looks
like
a foam hand you know with with like
these
protuberous things on it but it's
there's nothing intimidating about
there's no
claw it's moving so you know slowly and
laboriously because it's obviously a
very
um you know restrictive sort of thing
that they've got on the
on the performer's arm so it's just
[Music]
and then it just crumbles to dust
neither of which is intimidating
whatsoever
and yet despite the fact that it is far
too silly a concept and an execution in
terms of seeing these things
and also like the oh because i forgot to
mention there was one other shot
that worked and it's when they're coming
through the fire and that lighting is
about the only time that their big
mouths actually work because otherwise
because it's fixed and it doesn't move
in any way
after the first time you see it you're
kind of like oh it's just going to be
like that isn't it
so that doesn't really work either
actually aren't the big jaw things isn't
that also kind of like what amnesia the
dark descent
had its monsters like this is literally
occurring to me as i
say it oh man was the writer a fan of
that game i'm starting to wonder
anyway okay so now despite all that and
despite the fact that the monsters are
ineffective and
very poorly executed and the concept is
laughable on
its face it's also too scary
and i almost never accuse doctor who
being too scary but i say this from the
perspective of someone who has a kid
a kid who does not watch doctor who to
be fair but
who knows and oh and i think being a
parent kind of
puts you back in the headspace as well i
having now seen the world a bit through
my daughter's eyes i can
roll my mind back and sort of latch on
to what it was like to be
you know that age and as silly
as this gunk in the corner of your eye
concept is
it's also the kind of thing that would
latch on into a kid's head
and i remember somebody making a comment
might even have been on my
original review video being you know in
taking uh the role of a king going mommy
is the eye gunk gonna kill
me when i go to sleep and i think they
were saying that mockingly but the thing
is i could actually see
a younger doctor who fan having that
idea
lodged in their head because it doesn't
get properly explained it doesn't get
properly defeated and it's something
that
you know a more impressionable audience
member is going to wake up and find in
their eye in the morning and have a
freak out and i know again like i don't
go on about this i think kids are
really resilient but this is the kind of
worm concept that's gonna get
stuck in there and be hard to dislodge
and it's not in service of anything
so it simultaneously manages to fail at
being scary while being presented in
such a way that i can't help but feel
like
this is gonna traumatize some kids and i
don't feel that way about say
the silence or even the weeping angels
because at the very least
they get beaten at the end
that's another thing this whole thing at
the end where you know the guy recording
first of all
oh huge surprise the the scientist
who created the thing that started the
problem who died in a way that was
almost impossible to tell what happened
to him
turns up again he's the one behind it oh
what a
shock that was then he has the thing at
the end and
like he rubs his eye and he's it starts
to fall apart
he's saying that the signal the very
video that you're watching is implanting
this thing in you so now this will
happen to you
doctor who doesn't end like this
it just does that's that's kind of
violating the basic principle of
family entertainment one of the things
walt disney used to say is it is totally
okay to scare kids
as long as everything is okay in the end
and i kind of think that is how doctor
who should
approach its scary elements whether it's
the daleks the weeping angels the
silence the flood
whatever it is it has to be beaten
at the end of the episode so that as
scary as it can get
younger audiences because this is still
billed as a family show
still get to go oh well that was scary
but at least
we won here they didn't it also never
comes back to it which makes the whole
cliffhangery thing all the more stupid
and pointless because it's setting up
like it's
go well no i was gonna say it's setting
up like they're gonna follow up on it
but it's obvious they're never gonna
follow up
they're doing it because it's the
generic way to end a horror movie and
they think they're scary and they're not
the performances from the supporting
cast are not exceptional either but it's
because the characters are
so thinly sketched they're all
completely generic
like the there's actually the voiceover
from the guy towards the front end and
says
don't get too attached to them and i
remember i i actually said at the tv
yeah no there was no chance of that
happening buddy don't even worry about
it
about the best thing that i can say
about this thing is that there are a
handful of small moments or lines or
exchanges that i do
like but they are small potatoes in this
thing
so like the doctor's saying to clara
hold my hand
and she says i'm okay and he goes i'm
not and she holds his hand
i actually really love that moment i
mean as someone who
you know finds touch and contact
very reassuring if if i'm stressed or
afraid
that that moment is wonderful i wish it
was in a better
episode i also and this is this is just
me um i do really like that when
the captain of this team says to the
doctor consider yourself and he goes
part of the furniture
because the play i was in in seventh
grade that gave me that really gave me
the acting bug
was oliver and that's what that that's
what the song consider yourself is from
so
that that was a joke that felt like that
was just for me and that was kind of
nice
oh you know what here was a weird thing
that i noticed and did not remember at
all
there's um there's this repeated thing
that they keep doing of
uh may the gods bless you they say it a
lot
like any exclamation they say it
or anytime they're trying to get a hold
of somebody over the radio or whatever
they're like may the gods bless you are
you there i'm like
wait what and not that i'm saying you
can't have that kind of thing but what
is that in aid of
it's actually contradictory with most of
the rest of the stuff going on because
everything else that's going on in terms
of what we find out about this
setting is very corporate it's this idea
of
sleep is time wasted time is money stop
sleeping
like that is more in line with something
like frankly oxygen
next series but here we have out of
nowhere this
very prolific religious and spiritual
notion may the gods bless you
and it doesn't fit the themes and it it
can't even count as world building
because it doesn't get explained here
and this isn't a world that we're ever
going to come back to
this particular time and area setting so
what the hell was the point of that
what was that meant to illustrate oh and
another point of failure
there's this build up to this morpheus
machine and it looks like a coffin
that and then the the doctor got not the
doctor but the
scientist guy the villain he says like
there's someone in here who hasn't slept
in five years
and that feels like a buildup to
something even more monstrous than what
we already saw and what emerges from
this thing is just another freaking dust
monster
so what was the point of the build up
what was the purpose of the build up
if it's just gonna be the same dang
thing again
maybe it was slightly larger i couldn't
tell because the way the thing was shot
actually you know what there was one
other thing i liked the one other moment
and unfortunately it was a moment that i
liked was when the guy tried to get
through the door and the door made him
sing
and the door sounds like gladys from
portal in order to enter rooms
everyone must do the song it's very
amusing
but you know who i am just call me by my
name nevertheless
i actually really like that and i wish
in hindsight
i wish that this had been a the
station's computer has gone nuts
i wish it had been that kind of story
because that moment of him
trying to negotiate getting this door
open and being forced to sing by this
stubborn ai that was a great tense
darkly funny moment and that was the
kind of thing like i would have loved to
have seen spread across this but no it's
just
really really really really stupid
monsters and a mad scientist because we
never see those when was the last time
doctor had
had an ai go mad i can't remember now
off the top of my head
gus maybe you know from mummy in the
orient express but he was a background
feature
not to mention we never found out what
his deal was anyways
i think that's about all i've got i
really don't like this episode i didn't
like it when i first saw it
i it just immediately made me go oh dear
god what were they thinking
and it's it is a handful of gimmicks
slapped over a
lousy ineffective idea given an actually
absurdly
dark ending that is in no way cathartic
or reassuring which i don't think is
fitting for what doctor who
should be or at the very least what it
is still being billed as
and it's just got this handful
smattering tiny moments
that do nothing to stave off the
garbage that the rest of this episode is
i really hate this one sleep no more
you rewatched it lately what'd you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it i have a patreon
it helps keep this whole thing going and
i also have
a merch store and social media links and
you can like share subscribe comment all
those things help me out links in the
description were applicable
but you also don't have to end of the
day you're the council
i'm just running the meeting and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
so um
[Music]